the thing we're talking about today the
draft of
the teams that will make the playoffs
that didn't make it last year the party
crashes to the playoffs and we know the
turnover is great every single year
so that's where we are today i have the
trivia question for chris
chris here we go the buccaneers have the
second longest active playoff drought in
the nfl 12 seasons
the browns currently have the longest
with 17. name the starting quarterback
of the last tampa bay buccaneers playoff
game
which came in the 2007 wild card round
oh wow jeez this is
i mean this is what color is blue i mean
there's jeff garcia of course i was on
the damn team
so i'm not that crazy uh
hey hey hey pete what are you doing
pete forget pete forgot you were still
on the team yeah well yeah that's that
peeps you know that's
pete's a great friend he knows a lot
about my life as you can tell i mean
thanks pete thanks a lot yeah i was
stalling the team i was barely a year
after
dying so yeah i was i was there still
sorry uh yep yep i was so
i get the first pick on the draft right
yeah you do
yeah you get another gift you get you
get a birthday gift two days later yeah
good
i don't really want to take the bucks
but i know you're going to take them so
i'm taking the bucks from you okay here
we go i'm going with bucks as a playoff
party crasher i really
am i mean listen there's too many things
on the roster not to like regardless you
know am i skeptical in some ways
and some things i definitely am but with
brady and gronk and good tight ends to
go along with it and the wide receivers
they have
a special front seven yeah they're
certainly one of the teams i look at to
be
you know the the the new team in the
playoffs that didn't make it from last
year it's a very talented roster and i
think the brady effect like what you
talked about
you know it is real how he got that team
together in the off season
getting everybody on the page
everybody's holding themselves probably
a little bit more accountable than in
years past down there
because brady's on their butt all the
time and all those things too so
uh i will take tampa bay yeah i don't
know if that would have been my first
pick no
i think he left a better one you're full
of it you are so full i left a better
one on the board
i think from the standpoint of making
the playoffs right
i i i just said they're going to win the
suit they could win the super bowl you
didn't say the colts could win the super
bowl so stop
trying to just crap on my picks just to
crap on my picks all right
and i did say the worst case of the
buccaneers is make the playoffs yes
uh the worst case for the cults i did
not say was make the playoffs i'll agree
with you though okay thank you but you
know i'm taking the cults yeah
uh i yeah there are a couple of teams in
the afc that i think
i would select but the one that jumps
out to me a team that was 7-9 last year
despite having andrew luck retire a
couple of weeks before the start of the
season
and then having a good start i think
they were five and two at one point
so and then jacob got injured and it all
fell apart for them after that
and uh they were a team that could have
made it should have made it and would
have made it last year if percent had
stayed healthy all season long
he was never the same once he came back
from that mcl injury
so with philip rivers assuming we're not
going to see on a weekly basis the guy
who was throwing up interceptions in
prime time games last year
seven in back-to-back prime time games i
think the colts do enough to get in
especially with that seventh spot
available
give me the colts is my first pick yeah
i'm with you that's right
i'm gonna i honestly i i feel like
there's things i like about their team
and their roster and their chances maybe
more than the bucks in a lot of ways
uh but it's a pretty damn good football
team it's got so you're saying you
should have picked the call well i said
i just wanted to pick the bucks
for sure just to mess up your draft all
right i just felt good about that on a
monday
uh late in august so they just felt
right i'm going to the pittsburgh
steelers that's my next team
i mean it's a super bowl caliber defense
that's the first thing i'll say
i mean it's one of the best in the game
they were winning games by themselves
almost last year
and then i think you know big ben being
back the addition of chase claypool
all of those things i think that of
course is going to
help this offense immensely and then
eric ebron being there at the tight end
position along with vance mcdonald
uh i look at pittsburgh as being one of
those teams to jump back on the scene in
a big way this year
they were too good too talented last
year just had issues at quarterback
couldn't make any plays in the pass game
that won't be a problem this year the
reason i passed over them for the colts
i'm more concerned about the durability
of ben roethlisberger than i am the
durability of phillip rivers even though
we should be concerned about both
i still wonder whether or not the elbow
thing last year
was a sign of things to come and this
year it's going to be something else and
next year it's going to be something
else
and his body is in the process of
breaking down because
of the abuse it's taken the physical
pounding it's taken over the years uh
being a guy who has
always had someone hanging all over him
and you know you carry around
a lot of weight and he's a big guy on
those joints
it may be time for a rebellion of
basically every joint
from his hips to his knees to his ankles
alright uh next one for me
and i'm a little hesitant here to say
cowboys
but they were eight and eight last year
and they almost
so good at under achieving they'll find
another way to do it but
seven spots
this out this year and they're kind of
on that vikings every other year vibe
anyway
right so this is a year the vikings
don't make it so the cowboys take their
spot instead
uh it's not gonna take much of an
improvement to get in position to get
one of the seven
spots in the nfc and with mike mccarthy
there that kick in the butt and cd lamb
dak prescott in another contract year
ezekiel elliott with a chip on his
shoulder
that that rotation of pass rushers
they're grooming i think it's enough to
get the cowboys in
yeah i i i think that would have been my
next pick mike
certainly just too many talented guys on
the roster
yeah you're right the kick in the butt
by mike mccarthy you know
mike nolan on the defensive side i think
that's worth you know that energy
and everything like that is worth a win
or two to improve that football team at
the very least so
i'm with you there oh man
this is where it's tough this is really
tough i mean i got like four teams i
feel like i could pick for
for this you know what i'm gonna go on a
limb because i want to and i'm rooting
for it to happen
and i'm rooting for the city and i'm
going to cleveland browns i am
i'm going with it i don't care i just i
i mean
damn hopefully they learn from last year
kevin stefanski seems very even keel
has a plan knows how he wants to
approach the year
joe woods as the defensive coordinator
and then a lot like the cowboys
it's just the roster so damn good
you know you just you look at the front
four you look at the receivers the
offensive lines improve
now you know they're running backs some
young secondary guys that i
that you like okay a little unproven
there but uh i i'm i'm going with the
browns i am i mean i thought about the
chargers they're in that conversation
the rams the falcons uh but i don't know
i just want
i want to you know i still haven't seen
that i know i don't care you know the
teams that are available go ahead
all right i'm gonna go with the falcons
then yeah if you're gonna leave the
falcons i'm going with the falcons
finished six and two the second half of
last year
and again that that extra spot is
all the difference in the world and and
we're so caught up in saints and bucks
and saints and bucks and saints and
bucks i could see the falcons
kind of sneak in and and maybe swipe one
of those spots and a point that i think
peter king made
the the idea that uh if you get us
you could you could get a very
compelling two and seven match up
between teams from the same division
yeah you could
uh which which you you go from
previously having a buy as the team with
that two seed
to now having to welcome to town a team
that you play twice a year every year
that is not intimidated by you at all
and would not love nothing more than to
kick your ass out of the playoffs
before the playoffs even truly gets
started uh the the falcons if they get
that seventh seed and it's the
buccaneers of the saints
that could be a very very dangerous game
right out of the gates but i think the
falcons good enough to get there
you know health is going to be an issue
for all these teams but uh if they can
continue
that momentum that we saw last year this
is a team that i think should breeze
into the postseason chris
yeah i i don't i don't you know i i i
get you i mean the falcons it's
it's big time talent on that football
team across the board
yeah it's all comes down to the injury
bug can they stay healthy they're very
top-heavy
you know two or three injuries early on
in the year the last two years have
basically ruined their season
to where they just don't have guys that
can fill in so you know
maybe a little bit more depth on the
team this year but health is going to be
the big issue for them and if they can
stay healthy they're going to be
dangerous
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports